Traductor: Mireia Romero
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
La arena del desierto del Sahara
alcanza temperaturas superiores
a los 80 ºC cada día.
Con una dimensión de aproximadamente
nueve millones de quilómetros cuadrados,
este enorme desierto recibe cada año
unos 22 millones de teravatios-hora
de energía solar.
Eso es más de 100 veces la energía
que la humanidad consume anualmente.
Así que, ¿podríamos resolver nuestros
problemas energéticos para siempre
si cubriéramos el desierto
con paneles solares?
Los paneles solares funcionan
cuando las partículas de luz
llegan a su superficie
con la suficiente fuerza
para deshacer los nudos estables
de electrones.
Mientras se vuelven a estabilizar,
estos electrones producen electricidad.
Sin embargo, la energía que los paneles
pueden generar es limitada.
Las placas solares solo pueden interactuar
con longitudes de ondas de luz concretas,
de modo que es imposible convertir
más de la mitad de luz solar que reciben.
Además, algunas de las partículas de luz
que pueden convertir rebotan en el panel
sin siquiera tocar un solo electrón.
Pero gracias a científicos
e ingenieros inteligentes
y a la sustancial inversión
de los gobiernos,
las placas solares están generando
más energía que nunca.
Las capas anti reflectantes y las formas
grabadas en la superficie de los paneles
crean más oportunidades de impacto entre
las partículas de luz y los electrones.
Estas técnicas han aumentado la eficiencia
de las placas solares comerciales
hasta un 25 %
y los modelos experimentales
han llegado al 47 %.
Y es más, la energía solar se ha abaratado
un 89 % en la última década
en parte gracias a las cadenas
de suministro globales
para otras tecnologías
que usan los mismos materiales.
Juntos, estos factores
han convertido la energía solar
en la fuente de electricidad
más barata en la Tierra.
Países como India, China,
Egipto y Estados Unidos
ya han llevado
estas nuevas placas al desierto.
Sus plantas fotovoltaicas ocupan
desde 15 hasta 56 km2
y, cuando el sol
está en su punto más alto,
estas plantas pueden proveer energía
para cientos de miles
de residentes locales.
Pero estas plantas fotovoltaicas
llegan a temperaturas muy altas.
La luz que los paneles no transforman
o reflejan se absorbe como calor,
lo cual reduce la eficiencia del panel.
Y los sistemas de refrigeración
usados en muchas plantas
pueden llegar a usar
grandes cantidades de energía
al usar ventiladores o mover agua
para mantener una temperatura óptima.
Incluso con estos sistemas, los paneles
del desierto absorben mucho más calor
que el propio entorno arenoso natural.
Esto no ha sido un problema
en las plantas fotovoltaicas existentes.
Pero si intentáramos llenar el Sahara
de paneles solares,
el efecto podría generar enormes cambios
en el clima de la región.
Construir plantas fotovoltaicas
ya altera los ecosistemas locales,
pero una planta de esta magnitud
podría transformar drásticamente
el paisaje del desierto.
Por suerte, los paneles solares
no son nuestra única opción.
Algunas de las plantas
más grandes del mundo
ya han adoptado una nueva metodología:
espejos gigantes.
La planta solar de Noor en Marruecos,
que llegará a cubrir aproximadamente
30 km2 del Sahara,
es una central térmica solar concentrada.
Este diseño refleja la luz a un receptor
que primero convierte esa energía
en calor y entonces en electricidad.
Estos espejos producirán
un cambio de temperaturas
peligroso para la fauna local,
pero hay menos posibilidades
de que transformen el paisaje.
Y como se necesita tiempo
para que se enfríen
los materiales que se han calentado,
estas plantas seguirán produciendo energía
incluso después del atardecer.
Tanto si usan paneles como espejos,
las plantas industriales de energía solar
son generalmente fáciles de incorporar en
infraestructuras energéticas existentes.
Pero es mucho más difícil
transportar esa energía
más allá de la red eléctrica local.
Algunos países están trabajando
para encontrar
el modo de conectar redes eléctricas
alrededor del mundo.
Y muchas plantas almacenan energía
en baterías enormes
o convierten la electricidad
en gas limpio que se pueda usar luego.
Pero en el día de hoy, estas técnicas aun
son demasiado caras e ineficientes.
Y lo que es peor:
las energías renovables industriales
pueden tener los mismos problemas
que los combustibles fósiles
al depender de operaciones
mineras destructivas
y de cadenas de suministro
que emiten carbono mundialmente.
Afortunadamente, la energía solar
puede existir en muchos niveles,
desde las plantas solares industriales
hasta instalaciones más pequeñas
que den energía a edificios
y comunidades rurales.
Estos proyectos pueden complementar
el uso energético
o ser una fuente de energía pasiva
para regiones más remotas.
Y como los componentes necesarios
para los paneles son pocos y sencillos,
son rápidos de instalar
y relativamente fáciles de actualizar.
De hecho, es precisamente
esta flexibilidad lo que ha permitido
que la energía solar se haya abaratado
y extendido en la última década.
Así que si queremos mantener el creciente
uso energético de la humanidad,
necesitaremos respuestas grandes
y también pequeñas.